la idea de la ingeniería genética es
algo que asociamos con el siglo actual
ni siquiera sabíamos que los genes eran
en realidad el mecanismo de la herencia
hasta mediados del siglo 20 y la
modificación directa de los genes para
algún propósito en realidad inició hasta
los años 70 pero vale la pena señalar
que los seres humanos han estado
influyendo de alguna manera en la
genética de los organismos desde hace
mucho mucho tiempo por ejemplo en la
naturaleza tenemos algo que se ve así lo
llamamos lobo pero en la actualidad en
nuestras vidas tenemos cosas que se ven
así estos perros no surgieron
naturalmente surgieron de muchas
generaciones de crianza en las que los
seres humanos usaron lobos o zorros y
seleccionaron algunos rasgos
probablemente seleccionaron rasgos en
los que tal vez eran pequeños y se veían
como cachorros aunque fueran maduros o
rasgos que son más dóciles que
escucharán lo que los seres humanos les
decían que hicieran o características
que los hicieran buenos para cazar ruedo
o lo que sea y con el tiempo después de
la selección repetida de esos rasgos
llegamos a lo que vemos como diferentes
razas de perros y aunque los humanos
estuvieron haciendo esto por cientos y
miles de años influyendo en el adn que
se pasaba de una generación a otra no
sabían sobre el código genético real
aunque estuvieron haciendo una forma de
manipulación genética del mismo modo en
el reino vegetal cuando vamos al
supermercado y vemos una manzana dulce
puede ser que no haya existido antes de
la forma en la que la vemos hoy es muy
probable que como con la mayoría de los
productos agrícolas la gente podría
haber encontrado manzanas silvestres y
podríamos estar hablando de hace miles
de años encontraron árboles silvestres
de manzanas déjenme dibujar un árbol de
manzanas aquí
y probablemente encontraron que las
manzanas estaban un poco amargas
pequeñas difíciles de comer y de digerir
pero a través del tiempo las personas
fueron seleccionando los árboles que
tenían las manzanas más dulces y más
grandes favoreciendo las condiciones
para que fuera más probable que se
reprodujeran entonces con el tiempo
tenemos manzanas más grandes y dulces
como las que vemos en el supermercado
como lo mencioné muchos productos
agrícolas que tenemos en la actualidad
son el resultado de cientos o miles de
años de este tipo de cultivo entonces
aunque esa no sea la definición formal
de ingeniería genética que generalmente
se refiere a la modificación genética
que solo hemos podido hacer en las
últimas décadas los seres humanos han
estado ejerciendo algún tipo de
influencia en el adn de los organismos
por mucho mucho tiempo pero habiendo
dicho esto en las últimas décadas hemos
logrado ser más precisos en la
influencia del adn mediante la
ingeniería genética
en otros vídeos abordaremos con más
detalle cómo se está haciendo esto pero
tenemos la idea de adn recombinante
donde podemos tomar genes de un
organismo y ponerlos en otro organismo y
te preguntarás esto para qué sirve bueno
digamos que hay un árbol que quieres que
crezca digamos que es un árbol de
manzanas pero es susceptible a cierto
tipo de enfermedad y si esa enfermedad
lo afecta
pierdes toda tu cosecha pero qué pasa si
puedes insertar en el adn de ese árbol
de manzanas un gen que lo haga más
resistente a esa enfermedad y eso es lo
que la gente está haciendo en la
actualidad
entonces insertarán adn y podría ser de
cosas bastante salvajes
he leído historias sobre la inserción de
adn de insectos en plantas con el fin de
que sean de alguna u otra manera más
robustas ahora esta idea de adn
recombinante y comida genéticamente
modificada generalmente se le conoce
como organismos modificados
genéticamente
es algo controversial mucha gente dice
que es bueno que permite crear comida
más robusta de hecho parte de ese adn
recombinante insertar adn podría hacerlo
más nutritivo podría proveer más
vitaminas pero otras personas argumentan
que no sabemos exactamente las
repercusiones que podrían ocurrir al
hacer esto podríamos pensar que es útil
pero cuando tomamos adn de un organismo
y lo ponemos en otro cómo afecta eso la
nutrición o cuáles serán los efectos a
largo plazo de comer eso entonces es
algo en lo que puedes pensar y cuando
empezamos a pensar en estas preguntas
entramos en el campo de la bioética
conforme vamos teniendo más control
sobre el genoma y especialmente sobre el
genoma humano hay preguntas que tenemos
que hacernos es bueno o es malo pero
regresando a la idea de ingeniería
genética y de adn recombinante podríamos
hacer otras cosas digamos que
necesitamos producir insulina para
diabéticos
bueno tal vez podríamos tomar una célula
de una bacteria e insertar dentro de la
célula de la bacteria un gen que nos
ayude a producir insulina y luego de
repente esa bacteria podría convertirse
en una fábrica productora de insulina
humana de manera que podríamos tener
insulina para diabéticos y cosechar esa
insulina ese es un uso de adn
recombinante de modo que estamos
entrando en un periodo interesante de la
humanidad durante miles de años
estuvimos creando cosas pero ahora
estamos aprendiendo a manipular las
cosas a un nivel de detalle muy fino
esto nos hace hacernos todo tipo de
preguntas es probable que haya cosas muy
buenas que podamos hacer producir nuevas
medicinas producir cultivos más robustos
pero también hay preguntas sobre cuáles
serán los efectos secundarios y la
bioética se vuelve realmente interesante
cuando comenzamos a pensar en modificar
el genoma humano porque cuando
modificamos la genética no solo
modificamos un organismo modificamos
todos
pendientes modificamos los genes que
existen en el conjunto de genes y hay
algunos buenos argumentos para modificar
el genoma humano como corregir
enfermedades que podrían ser muy serias
pero con el tiempo la gente podría decir
oye yo quiero ser un poco más alto o yo
quiero tener un cierto color de cabello
o yo quiero tener los dientes más
alineados o podrían decir quiero un hijo
que tenga esta u otra característica
entonces las cosas se vuelven muy
interesantes en tanto más pensamos en
los usos de la ingeniería genética nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo